hey guys this is dennis the founder
think era and i'm david griffin your
resident comic book and video game guru
and this is our review of breaking bad
season 5 episode 10 buried yeah so the
episode actually starts off not where we
left off the kind of cliffhanger of the
last episode but it starts off with with
uh Jesse Pinkman yes and that old man
find the money and then in and finding
him would it would you make out of that
I like the opening it was cool I mean
it's kind of following his trail of
breadcrumbs almost and she's Jesse on
the carousel they're just kind of going
around its kind of crazy look in his
eyes I don't know as part of me was
watching Jesse go through this almost
seems like I don't know about his
transformation it seems like it's almost
too drastic because I realized that he
feels guilty you know the kid died in
front of him Todd shot that kid I get it
but like he's been in the life of crime
for a long time like he knows this kind
of stuff happens like so part of me I
don't get why he's going so crazy and so
weird right now I mean I know he has
been through a lot I get it but I don't
know I just some of it i'm like i don't
i don't quite feel for Jesse yet I don't
know I'm just I don't know yeah and then
you know at the end of the episode we
see that he's brought in they found him
with the money you know now the question
is is well are they gonna be able to get
anything out of him or I be able to turn
him because we don't know where his
mental state is right now like he like
is he trying to get caught yeah like you
don't know if he's trying to get caught
you you don't know how loyal he may or
may not be too Walt anymore maybe he
wants to turn on him or maybe he wants
to say something my guess is maybe he
feels guilty um but he wants to get
punished in a way but he I don't think
he wants to take Walt down with him I
have a feeling that it's his own thing
like he's saying I feel guilty for this
so I need to be punished like if Walt
doesn't feel guilty that's his deal you
know right I agree I can't see him to
start like crying and start saying well
you know mr. white did this and did this
yeah I think I think you
I think he's on self-destruction mode
right now I think he likes I think he's
trying to answer for his crimes he's
just doing it a crazy way I just I he's
just he's just looks like he's on drugs
which is not he's actually I haven't
seen him actually you know do that he's
just he's just crazy right now you know
so now we you know back to like Walton
Hank in the garage the aftermath of that
becomes this whole like all right let me
call you know Skyler in that whole thing
and kind of just kind of brought up a
lot more like paranoia for Walt cuz he
you know he couldn't get ahold of skyler
it immediately assumed that she was
spilling her guns when she wasn't she's
actually Skyler kind of impressed me
this episode she was she was tough I
mean in the end she's like years like
look we're not turning ourselves in this
is not gonna happen you know it's gonna
make us look more guilty I mean she she
was tough this episode she stood strong
I mean she went kind of crazy in the
restaurant me like I'm i under arrest
you little ramp but she was tough this
episode I liked her well yeah cuz she
didn't know what was going on you know
she she still feels loyalty to Walt and
also she doesn't know what Hank actually
can prove right like she knows that Hank
knows but at the same time she's like
well is he trying to like get me thrown
in jail as well and what about their
kids and so she's kind of thinking of
like the whole picture so yeah she she
did impress me I mean this is a
character that you know through the
seasons I have always said I kind of
find her annoying sometimes you know but
in this episode I found her like it's
weird because it's like she's protecting
her her like criminal husband and the
same time it's like I'm you know I like
her character more for it right i mean i
liked we also saw more about Skylar
realize that Hank is on he's on revenge
I mean he's just you know possessed with
always like anger and frustration he
wants to go after a while he wants to
take him down with everything he has I
mean even you know talking to hang
talking to his wife you know a scholar
sister and just saying like look I maybe
we shouldn't go in right now be a
laughingstock so yeah but if you don't
go in and we'll be worse later on and
his mind just not in the right place
he's going at this from completely a
state of revenge not oh this is the
right thing to do with the police office
please embarrassed yeah he's
embarrassing to this you know this whole
thing has been right
I used to pick on one wall all the time
they were in the first couple seasons
he's always like y'all doing this like
not the tough guy out wall has everybody
scared I mean skip ahead a little bit i
love this scene with what's-his-name
sigh Saul's a bodyguard they're late on
the money doing the whole Scrooge McDuck
thing and I love that they were scared
to take the money they're like hey
they're worried we're like that dude
killed all those guys in prison within
like 20 minutes I mean he has a
reputation exactly ya mean it's that
reputation it's like the myth Allah it's
like Keyser Soze and gradual suspect
it's like becomes this thing that he's
probably he's not I mean he is a
criminal but I mean he's not that
hardcore no um but did you know they're
so scared and not even gonna take the
money right now but I mean they're gonna
get paid anyways and then you know and
then Walt codes and berries all that
stuff I did think it was interesting
though because he couldn't get ahold of
Skylar and Skylar tried to contact him
yeah and Saul wouldn't let him answer
the phone and so she started getting
paranoid about what where he was and
what he was doing and he was getting
paranoid that like she would like turned
on him and like great I mean even now
like she's he's like still a little you
know kind of a skeptical of Skylar you
know yeah he's like remember at the end
when he he passes I just promise me
you'll take the money and you know I'll
you know I'll confess to everything as
long as you take the money keep it for
the kids you know so like he he's kind
of just figuring that that's what she
wants to do yeah I mean that's probably
my for my favorite scenes of the episode
was just him laying on the bathroom
floor just just out of it and waking up
and Skylar's kind of had a moment I
liked it when I heard about the cancer
and she come to realization okay maybe
he does we haven't heard I mean we
assume he does have the cancer it's all
back I mean was seeing everything it's
been going on she said you know or he
said does that make you happy and she's
like you know I've been happy in a long
time like nothing's really making me
happy right now life sucks but I think
at that moment even though he said I
don't think maybe he trust her
completely I think they found some
connection there I think they're both at
a place at a point in life where they
don't want to be like they're both not
happy
they're both not happy and they're both
like oh they don't want to suffer the
consequences of their actions cuz wow
she is nowhere near as you know guilty
as well she has done some thing and even
like when her sister confronted her and
try to steal her baby from her it could
click scenario than her uh yeah
kleptomania yeah well hurt hurt you know
Skyler the guilt sin in and all that
stuff came up and she's trying to keep
her life as it is but but to Hank and
Marie they're just like their minds are
blown yeah you know they're like oh my
god you know that you know like at first
they kind of thought she was like much
more innocent than they realized that
she was gonna ask you uh because it
knows maybe out the beer got the biggest
fan of her character but what did you
think of the scene with Lydia out in the
desert of course we see Todd comes back
did you do you still kind of a noise
Lydia kinda want to see her go and you
respect her her tenacious naitch I mean
would like we think about it right now I
mean the thing is is that's just such a
move on her part you know it's just so
like her it's like she wants to you know
continue on you know getting all this
money from you know selling the math but
at the same time she's she doesn't want
to see any of the dirty work right now
like the whole like covering her I like
you know like I like fire in the hole
like so like yeah so it's just very true
to our nature which is that she's very
paranoid in prayer she always liked
wants to you know get her way you know
the way she went to Walt last episode
and now this time trying to get them to
like change their mind about using Todd
when like like she's like screw it you
know but at the same time she doesn't
want to she doesn't want even look at
you know she kind of compartmentalizes
the kind of stuff that she's done oh
yeah yeah she's I don't think she's
different she's like a compu somewhere
in between I think Walt and Jesse and
Todd like Walt Jesse and I think even
wall as crazy as he is has some kind of
moral character I think Jesse
obviously does super emotional guy she's
not Taj not completely just cold and
turned off like he is but she has she
doesn't care but I think she does catch
somewhere in between those two guys
she's interesting care i like her more
after that scene in this episode i did
in previous episode yeah well it's gonna
be interesting yeah that you know how
Todd and his his I guess his you know
family right are gonna take over this
business supposedly and how that plays
in to Walt we don't know how that's
going to affect wall have a feeling that
Todd strikes wall yeah I think he looked
up to him so I don't think unless wall
to some stupid to mess something up I
think Todd was gonna is gonna be on his
side I think who knows how long it's
gonna last well I mean this guy shot a
kid so last year I feel like he is on
his side until he isn't on his side
right in there and then that'll be like
kind of a cold like cutting off like all
right we need to kill this guy yeah cuz
even yeah even Walt was like when Saul
suggested he kill Hank yeah he's like no
I can't kill him he's family I know even
even even as all this stuff is happening
that those are great calm I came from
what country was it Belize they were
saying that the reference are saying you
know just a offhand remark about sending
some killing somebody oh yeah in the
Belize and I like I was like all so new
to believe yeah remember that was that
the actual country but yeah I was for ya
alright so that's what we thought the
episode you can post your comments below
on the website st. CARICOM you also find
us on youtube on our youtube page just
think hero pro and we're also on Twitter
mine is at ping Kira I'm at Griffin de
and make sure you subscribe to our
YouTube channel it's a thick hair of pro
and we have a Facebook page facebook.com
slash think Carol fans
you